by now you've probably heard about this
new coronavirus epidemic that started in
China and spread to more than a dozen
countries in this new coronavirus is
part of this massive family of viruses
that includes everything from SARS on
one hand which is a deadly infection to
the common cold which is far from deadly
based on very early data we're seeing
that infected people seem to have a
fever a cough and a viral pneumonia so a
really bad chest infection seems a
little bit different to what we saw with
thoughts back in 2002 where people were
more likely to have a sore throat a
runny nose and diarrhea there's already
evidence that this new corona virus does
spread from person to person the
interesting thing is it seems to be more
infectious than SARS another corona
virus but less deadly so at the moment
we think that the death rate from the
new corona virus is around 2.5 to 3.5
percent for SARS it was in the double
digits it was at least 10 or 11 percent
the incubation period for the new corona
virus could be 3 to 6 days some experts
say but others say it could be as many
as 14 days that number keeps changing as
we get more information but here's one
of the worrying things it looks like
some people with this infection were
contagious even before they had any
symptoms themselves if that's true that
can make it trickier to get a handle on
the epidemic so what do you need to do
to protect yourself the answer to that
really depends on who you are and where
you are if you are in China you're gonna
have to take different precautions too
if you live in the United States so far
the guidance for Americans is practice
good hand hygiene because we're in the
middle of flu season and you should get
your flu shot because flu kills tens of
thousands of Americans every year and go
to a credible website like cdc.gov or
the WHI website and they will have
travel guidance there for you that's
updated day by day this new epidemic is
serious but here's the thing as this new
virus spreads so does misinformation
about the virus as well as a spread of
fear and panic if people get really
scared during an epidemic one thing that
they might do is descend on their local
hospitals using up resources and packing
the place when really the doctors there
need to focus on the people who are
seriously ill what you need during a
public health crisis is information and
calm and it's very frustrating to see on
social media that there are so-called
scientists and people who should know
better
really inciting panic and fear among the
public there's misinformation spreading
right now about the new coronavirus
outbreak everything from people saying
that you should drink bleach to cure it
please do not ever for any reason drink
bleach something I thought I would never
have to say but also really racist and
xenophobic things are spreading things
like you shouldn't go to Chinatown if
you live in London that's absolutely
ridiculous it's a racist nonsense this
is not the first time that
misinformation and disinformation about
an epidemic has been spread on social
media we saw this in 2014 to 2016
during the West African Ebola epidemic
we saw all sorts of rumors then things
like if you eat raw onions or eat ground
coffee that that would cure the disease
and not only was that not true but it
can be really harmful if somebody's
exposed to that and they believe that
more than they believe a credible source
something that's blowing my mind right
now with this new corona virus epidemic
is how quickly we are getting new
information there's already a hospital
in China trying out new antiviral
medicines there were already scientists
in different parts of the world working
on various vaccines for this corona
virus it would be amazing if one of the
experimental vaccines became available
during this epidemic but that's not
really likely just based on history and
how long it can take to develop a
vaccine and check it in animals and
check it for safety in humans but it is
still astonishing just how quickly we're
making progress you compare that to
previous epidemics we've had of new
infections we've been way behind before
and so with this outbreak I'm really
keeping a close eye on how different
authorities from different countries are
working with each other because you
can't deal with an epidemic as if it's
just one country's problem nowadays an
epidemic anywhere is a threat
everywhere the way that this might end
is that the infection just Peters out we
get a handle on the epidemic we find the
people who are sick and we also find
their close contacts to make sure that
they don't go on and pass the infection
to others it's a troubling outbreak but
it's something that we are expecting in
the public health world we're always
looking out for the next new virus the
next big epidemic what we're seeing with
this epidemic is public health systems
are gearing up and they are going into
action as they are prepared to what you
should do to stay safe is stay on top of
the news look for credible sources do
not believe the BS and be prepared but
do not panic and do not let anyone else
make you feel panicked
[Music]